that lineup will face logan webb off the
injured list tonight
logan webb
six one 215 pound 24 year old
making his first start coming off the
ill now tonight is probably going to be
limited to about 40 45 pitches which
means he could go three meetings uh
maybe less depending on how he throws
how much stress he has another one two
got him swinging with the fastball they
set a high target right across the
letters so one out and here is juan soto
hey logan webb got him to chase strike
three swinging and that's a sinker at 94
miles per hour now here's the powerful
josh bell bell
strike three called and logan webb
strikes out the side with an error mixed
in and is returned to the mound here's
paulo paula features a good fastball
four steam fastball slow curve ball
slider and a changeup he uses all four
pitches at any time
ski leads off with a walk now here is
alex dickerson dickerson swings away 3-0
and hits a little bloop
it's gonna fall well that's not exactly
what you dream of if you take a 3-0
swing but alex dickerson will take it
not darren ruff right-handed hitter with
power
he lines that one softly left center
field it gets down base hit josh
harrison scoops it up but yustrepski
scores and darren ruff puts the giants
ahead one nothing starlin castro leads
off for the nationals
castro a 12-game hitting streak eighteen
for 39
just under 500.
so here's gomes 268 average the 1-2 from
webb
got him swinging so he didn't go after
the slider so why not just come back and
throw the change up now here is gerardo
parra 2-2 pitch ground ball to short
crawford over to his right to get it
nobody's at second here's the throw to
first doesn't matter in time to get para
the inning is over solid single to the
left for donovan solano so here is kurt
casale
swinging there's a high drive deep left
center field way back there still going
goodbye
into the bleachers a two rod homer for
kurt casalli
against the right-hander espino
and that makes it three-nothing giants
casalli's third home run here's
dickerson
wrecking ball popped up trey turner
alone on the left side plenty of time to
grab that one chew down and here is
turner
turner pops it up
darren rough
solano makes the call and he'll catch it
mike you'd have to say pretty successful
return for logan webb that's exactly how
dave captain drew it up here's the
all-star shortstop brandon crawford
rolls it over
bell unassisted
here's darren ruff
fastball in on his hands
and harrison back to grab it josh will
have a little fun
probably faking a souvenir throw two on
no outs for starlin castro castro lines
this one to center field not that hard
hit duggar is there to make the catch
soto is going to tag here comes the
throw it's cut off by crawford
de soto good base running there duggar
had to angle back a little bit and was
flat-footed when he made his throw
so here's pereira right-handed batter
tres pereira
high flight ball
deep left center and it's off the wall
and it bounces away from duggar that'll
bring in two tres barrera heading for
third how's that for your first big
league rbis
the nets are back in it three to two now
the giants have the option to walk para
to get to the pitcher spot
that breaking ball by para and that will
tie the game
duggar cuts it off gerardo parra into
second
and the nats have a three spot here in
the fourth
using the big gaps
at oracle park oh one pitch espino
lights that one into center field that's
a hit duggar plays it on the bounce here
comes par around third here comes the
throw waiting casalli tags out para for
out number three giants needed that bad
6-7-8 for the giants
first pitch fastball away harrison there
josh messing with the fans out left
field again
gerardo clued him in on some of the
antics because you told me this is one
of the more interesting places to play
left field in all the baseball
and the bases are loaded now and now the
giants are going to pinch it and we'll
figure we can't see it yet but we'll
guess this is austin slater
trey turner there to grab that one and
then ants will dodge a bullet in the
fourth by catching a bullet to the
shortstop with two outs and here's josh
bell
he struck him out
changed up on him struck out both soto
and bell 3-3 tie here in the fifth
inning two down nobody on and so darren
rough comes up
deep left center field
way back there
goodbye two-thirds of the way up in the
bleachers in left center no less
wow
a moon shot from darren ruff to put the
giants back ahead
stressful situation for latel and the
giants in a one-run game tres barrera
comes up he tripled in two runs as last
time up
toward the middle crawford with a dive
he's got it and flips it right from the
glove bare handed by solano double play
alcides escobar the former royal
shortstop may have just said wait a
minute didn't i see something like that
in the world series well watch the glove
flip the only way he could get it over
to solano who takes it with the bare
hand and completes the double play this
is just brilliant that's the big leagues
the mound visit completed with
yastrimsky at the plate
yeah a couple of them
gets the pop-up escobar takes
charge so the mishap in left
does not hurt
and this one to the seventh run is at
second and third the infield in halfway
the pitch to trey turner turner ground
ball to short crawford is going to come
home the tag he's out at the play two
down now juan soto coming up and runners
at first and second soto goes after that
one and grounds it to second solano is
gonna throw him out what a job by
dominic leone first and third nobody out
some help from his defense but he got
out of it been a tough night for wilmer
with the bat he has struck out and twice
grounded out right-handed delivers and
there's a high drive in the deep left
center field hit really well way back
there still going
to
into the bleachers just to the left with
a 399 marker no cheapy that one
and the giants have a 5-3 lead and now
the bases are loaded for gerardo parra
para rolls one softly to second can the
giants turn two that's one crawford
defers got him double play
another spectacular double play
and now
bell will come up
that one is on the ground to short
crawford's got it and he'll throw out
josh bell the ball game's over jake
mcgee gets through it brandon crawford's
defense was a big reason why the giants
survived this game and they beat the
nationals by the final score of 5-3 to
take the first game of this series